hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery ant-man review I'll
do another video this weekend where I
get into Easter eggs and marvel phase 3
stuff just like a lot of Marvel films
there are a lot of visual teases and a
lot of verbal teases most most of the
comic book Easter eggs for like way back
in the classic comics were verbal things
so make sure you listen really carefully
whenever you go see it most of the
really big ones are really obvious and
really visual so you will definitely not
miss them be sure to stay through the
end credits though for all intents and
purposes this is the first Marvel movie
in a long time that feels like an actual
movie like less like a rollercoaster
ride and more like an actual character
based story but the type of story that I
think that they tried to tell with Iron
Man 3 but they just didn't come across
the problem with the Iron Man franchise
is that it had already gotten so big by
the time they got to Iron Man 3 that
it's like if we don't do a spectacle
then people are gonna hate it but they
wanted to tell this really a small story
because they just unavenged so but I
just don't think it quite worked out the
way they wanted it to ant-man definitely
lands and I think a lot of that is just
due to the reason that it doesn't try to
be bigger than it actually is like it
doesn't try to grow to gigantic
proportions you know just to start
making ant-man puns Giant Man puns I
mean it's a Marvel movie it definitely
ties in with all the other movies it's
it's like the last little end tag for
phase 2 Captain America Civil War is the
next Marvel movie coming next spring
that'll be the official beginning of
phase 3 so this movie is like the very
end of phase 2 the real mission here is
to sell Paul Rudd is the next potential
Avenger all the different versions of
ant men were Avengers at one time or
another Hank Pym Scott Lang even Erik
O'Grady Erik O'Grady the the
irredeemable ant-man was kind of an
[ __ ] though so whenever I go back and
read old ant-man stories again I usually
I just avoid his stuff he was kind of a
butthole a lot of people are asking you
know why they changed certain things
about the movie you know like people
wanted to see Hank Pym the Avengers
create Ultron well mark Marvel had
already set up a couple characters so
they had to change the narrative to just
fit that a little bit this movie was
adjusted accordingly but they do explain
like where Janet Van Dyne is a lot of
the classic ant-man stuff so as much as
they broken canon in the other Avengers
movies they definitely acknowledge that
in this movie they make it all work the
most interesting thing that I read about
the movie before
I want to see it this week like one of
the last things that I read about it had
to do with the way they constructed it
if you've ever read about some of the
more intense Hollywood directors like
David Fincher a lot of them only make
their movies in the editing Bay they
look at like hundreds and hundreds of
takes of scenes in all kinds of
different ways and then they'll just use
those like Lego bricks to make a movie
in the editing Bay that's not
necessarily a bad thing as long as there
is someone that knows what movie they
want and usually it's one of the
producers like Kevin Feige or the other
producers in the film Paul Rudd and the
other actors said that they never were
quite sure what they were shooting like
they they would just shoot scenes out of
context and they would always try a
bunch of different things each time they
were filming separate scenes so at
various points over the last couple of
months the movie itself like the ant-man
story changed like the Darren cross
character knew certain things about the
ant-man suit at certain times like the
way they cut the movie made the
narrative changed quite a bit it's just
really interesting to hear them make a
movie like that it might sound kind of
like a nightmare but if you've ever
tried to shoot a long youtube video and
like in you you've messed up a certain
part of it or you you didn't like the
way you did it you just you reshoot that
part and then you move it around a
little bit
construct the car Marvel movie sometimes
they do stuff like this just to preserve
some of the mystery around the film like
they have certain plot points that they
want to keep close to the vest like the
end credits scene a lot of the actors
had absolutely no idea where that was
going so whenever you go see Captain
America Civil War just just imagine that
most of the actors on that film have no
idea what's going on in the film that
they're shooting their scenes out of
context but what about Paul Rudd though
does he feel like an Avenger after this
movie I I certainly feel like he does
he's a very different kind of Avenger
he's kind of like the guy that's gonna
let the air out of the balloon think
about where the Avengers are gonna be in
civil war it's all about this conflict
between Captain America and Iron Man so
so Scott Lang has the job of being
someone who can go toe-to-toe with those
guys but also hasn't jumped up his own
butt as much as like say Iron Man has
Paul Rudd in real life is so much that
character to think about the other
movies that Paul Rudd has done and and
how that energy might fit with the
Avengers just the guy to walk in and
call them on their [ __ ] so if you
feel like you got lost in the story in
Avengers age of Ultron like there was
just like too much craziness going on
Paul Rudd Scott Lang character is the
one that's going to keep that story
grounded and that's one of the big wins
of the ant-man movie in that he's so
connected to his daughter when you see
the way the movie treats Scott Lang's
relationship with his daughter Cassie
Lang you'll understand why they changed
some of the things about Hank Pym like
they changed that to fit that narrative
this is some nice symmetry between Hank
Pym and Scott Lang even though they're
two completely different characters
speaking of Hank Pym Michael Douglas he
was a lot of fun he wasn't as big in
this movie as I expected him to be but
he was definitely a very important part
you definitely find out why he hasn't
been in a lot of these other Avengers
films and hope him Evangeline Lilly she
was like one of the last people they
cast for the movie she was at Comic Con
last year like not this past year but in
2014 to promote this book she had done
she was doing Hobbit stuff so she just
she came and sat in on the ant-man panel
she had literally been cast in the movie
just like days before comic-con had
started they didn't have a script yet so
I I didn't think that she was gonna be
that big in the movie but she really
like she walked away from this movie
stealing the show I feel like the
ant-man movie was built around Scott
Lang's character developing him you know
putting him forward as the next
potential Avenger but secretly the movie
was Evangeline Lily's it was it was all
about her character without overtly
telling you that I don't want to get too
crazy and despoilers about that yet I'll
totally explain with with phase three
related stuff there's a lot of really
awesome stuff in the movie but it's just
kind of spoilery if you haven't seen it
yet so be sure to go see the movie and
you'll understand why hope is every bit
as important as Scott Lang Kevin Feige
said that whenever they were planning
this movie like they'd said that they
had the a man character they want to
develop him so naturally they put Scott
Lang in the world just because Hank Pym
wasn't going to be the Avenger that he
was in the comics he said that they
really were just telling like the story
of the transition from Hank Pym to Scott
Lang and then like all this other phase
3 phase 2 crossover stuff got added in
at the last minute like whenever they're
baking their movie cake that's like the
last ingredient like the last thing they
put in and I don't think the movie ever
got overpowered by a lot of this need to
tie in these other big things I know
like that was one of the big criticisms
of say Iron Man 2 or was like it's
trying to set up too many things there
are too many characters that don't
matter for this story ant-man gets rid
of most of the fluff there aren't too
many contrived situations it doesn't go
outside of itself too much but they have
some like viral broadcasts to like you
know ty Scott Lang to the larger Marvel
Universe they're using they're
essentially using like news broadcasts
in the way that they use frontline in
the comics during civil war
hey this character is over here doing
this thing and it's loosely related to
what might be going on over here so even
in like the first 30 minutes of the film
you'll understand why Scott Lang even
though he's like like a nobody in the
context of his own story he is as
somebody in the context of the Marvel
Universe he's not just a common thief if
you guys have had a chance to see the
movie let me know what was your favorite
part and you know what are you really
looking forward to from the next ant-man
movie I feel like the movie sets up like
a couple clear pillars for where the
sequels might go without getting into
spoilers yet I'll just say this
typically sequels drill-down on
supporting cast so we might see a lot
more hope in the next sequel which is
what I'm really hoping for because I
like Evangeline Lilly and I really like
what they did with her character in this
film but you guys can let me know if you
agree do you want to see more of what
they're doing with the hope character as
I feel like she ended up being one of
the most interesting parts of the film
there's also one really big concept that
becomes part of the climax of the film
like the big final battle I know you
guys are all gonna be asking about that
but I'll try to answer questions about
that in my spoiler video this weekend
feel free to ask any questions you want
though just be sure to use spoiler tags
if you have seen the movie so what's
gonna happen is I think I'll just I'll
post my Easter egg spoiler video
tomorrow and I'll just I'll put spoilers
in the title just in case you guys need
to avoid it for like a day or two but be
sure to subscribe to get that I've also
got a couple other comic-con trailers I
haven't done yet I know everyone's
asking about vixen there's heroes reborn
stuff that's going on if there's any
other video requests that you guys want
to make stuff that I haven't done from
comic-con yet just let me know in the
comments there's still like a whole
bunch of stuff to talk about
and speaking of ant-man and Adams they
actually they just cast atom smasher on
the flash there's a whole bunch of like
arrow flash stuff going on too but I'm
gonna talk about that in separate videos
so why you guys wait for all that stuff
to post like what you'll you know buy
your tickets for ant-man you can click
here to learn all about Hank Pym in the
comics like his comic book history and
you can click here for all my Comic Con
trailer videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you